[Music]
just to give you a quick idea of the
scale that we operate on at Walmart I'm
sure many of you have heard about the
company Walmart so Walmart employees
around 2.3 million associates and we
serve around 270 million customers on a
weekly basis and we do this through you
know over 11,000 stores that we have and
you know various ecommerce systems and
all of this is operating in 28 countries
so you can imagine that even when we're
kind of planning to roll out some
internal application that is supposed to
cater our own internal associates we're
already having to deal with considerable
scale so that's quite interesting from a
platform perspective especially and the
other thing that's also very interesting
is the fact that Walmart has this kind
of two different kind of landscapes one
is these kind of large scale clusters
that you're operating in the cloud and
then we also have many kind of smaller
edge clusters that are all operating in
our stores and our distribution centers
so again from for a platform engineer
this is quite interesting now I'm sure
you're not here to here you're not here
to listen to me talk about how awesome
engineering at Walmart is so let's just
dive into the actual theme of this
presentation so once upon a time there
was a monolith perhaps multiple and of
course this monolith was beautifully
architected it made our life so great
and you know fulfilled so many business
values and of course my slides by the
way are an oversimplification of orders
of magnitude but essentially this
monolith was very modular we had various
modules inside of this thing and these
modules will essentially communicate
with each other to fulfill whatever
responsibilities they had and you know
the invocation between modules was some
form of you know in-memory invocation
function calls or method calls and you
know generally this actually brought us
a pretty long way until of course a
certain threshold was breached and we
woke up one day and we realized well the
size you know of the code base the
complexity of the overall system
you know the scalability challenges that
we're facing
in general the whole development
velocity is definitely not where it's
supposed to be anymore
and so you know we did the obvious thing
and you know at the time you know we
refer to it as you know introducing a
service-oriented architecture today we
kind of talk about it as or refer to it
as you know a microservices architecture
we broke up the monolith and decompose
it into individual services so in a
simplified sense essentially we took all
of those modules and made them
individual services and you know with
these individual services they're you
know we're able to kind of develop them
individually scale them individually and
and maintain them better of course we
had to change your whole engineering
culture at the company but life was much
better now and you know velocity came
back however of course you know by
solving the kind of old set of problems
that we had with the monolith now all of
a sudden we had a brand new set of
challenges that we had to solve with
this you know new architecture one of
the things is for example the the act of
you know service invocation is all of a
sudden very different like these arrows
in between the services become much more
critical and important then we have to
very much focus on them whereas in a
monolith you know when a module invokes
another module
essentially it's usually a simple matter
of preparing a stack and having the CPU
jump to a particular instruction now all
of a sudden we need to actually traverse
the network and this is something
obviously that you know can fail often
often and so we need some type of
resiliency
also how do all of these services
discover each other like how this you
know I know where to find service B and
if service B kind of changes its
whereabouts how does it you know how
this service a get notified of that and
how do we even like observe this overall
kind of large system how do we know
what's going on at any point in time
with our kind of larger infrastructure
and and debugging like how do we even
debug and trace kind of problems how do
we pinpoint you know the particular
source of any problem that were that
we're facing at in production and of
course you know orchestration you know
now that we're kind of invoking services
you know via remote calls somehow we
need some type of governance so
everything is done appropriately and we
need some type of policy enforcement so
we have all of these new challenges and
again we were
quite early to this and the first
solution to this new set of challenges
was to kind of introduce some type of
centralized intermediary and you can
think of like an enterprise service bus
or some type of you know API gateway of
sorts and the idea was pretty simple
essentially instead of having all the
services directly talk to each other and
instance here kind of point-to-point
connections now what they do is they
kind of talk through this centralized
intermediary and and it would take care
of like things like discovery and
routing and resiliency and policy
enforcement and observability and you
name it it was all there to a certain
extent and yes that certainly solved the
problems that we had you know when we
kind of naively decomposed our monolith
into you know individual micro services
but of course once again you know having
solved you know the current set of
problems we have now introduced a brand
new set of problems with this particular
architecture some of the most important
things is the fact that we've introduced
the single point of failure right when
since everyone all of the services are
relying on this you know kind of
centralized broker or intermediary of
sorts to communicate with each other if
this thing goes down obviously you know
no one can communicate with each other
and and we have a problem in addition we
also introduced kind of a different form
of scalability challenges because as our
micro services architecture is growing
and of course you know at Walmart we
went from you know dozens to hundreds to
thousands of services now we have you
know this centralized kind of system has
to account for the additional load and
throughput and and and overall weight
that is put on the system so we as a
platform team have to kind of constantly
maintain you know you know monitor this
thing and kind of keep scaling it up as
the usage of it grows of course
the latency da story isn't all that
great either here because you know when
we decompose the monolith of course and
we introduced remote invocations all of
a sudden you know our our Layton sees
went you know from in-memory to kind of
remote calls you know that that kind of
deteriorated the kind of performance
with orders of magnitude now all of a
sudden we're actually doing multiple
hops on a network
which you know is definitely another
great thing for performance overall and
you know from a kind of platform
perspective you know as we're trying to
kind of innovate and improve the overall
kind of platform whenever we're looking
to kind of make changes or you know add
new features or even you know fix bugs
you know at runtime we have to be very
careful because any change we do in this
kind of centralized system is impacting
all of the tenants at the same time so
that is kind of very tricky and at some
point you know our are kind of the
velocity of our improvements comes to a
grinding halt
and so the you know we obviously
recognize that the fact that you know
these problems that we're now facing are
due to the fact that we have this kind
of centralized nature you know our
solution has been centralized and that's
kind of the culprit of these particular
problems so the obvious kind of next
step is to take that centralized
solution and de-centralized it so at the
time the you know the the thing that we
came up with was to kind of create a you
know that's called the micro micro
services framework of sorts essentially
like a framework or a set of libraries
that take care of all of the same
concerns that you know the centralized
system was doing you know the same kind
of routing and discovery and resiliency
etc etc and you know thereby we would
kind of have this framework take care of
all of those requirements and we would
eliminate the need of this centralized
system now this certainly kind of solved
you know all of those problems we had at
that point in time but once again we've
kind of changed it architecture and we
went from you know old set of problems
and now all of a sudden we have a brand
new set of problems
once again the problems that we're
facing now for example is the fact that
these this particular solution is non
polyglot now in the case of Walmart our
and our engineering teams are free to
use whatever technology they would like
to use and the day view is the best fit
for their kind of use cases so you will
find any language any framework any set
of libraries being utilized in our
company
we as a platform team somehow have to
you know facilitate these kind of
platform concerns to you know for all of
these these technology stacks which in
this particular architecture essentially
boils down to us having to kind of port
this micro services framework to all of
the different technology stacks which is
definitely quite the overhead on our
team in addition the the actual kind of
micro source framework now is all of a
sudden hard-coded into the application
so your platform is now you know
actually you know a part of the actual
applications and thereby this makes kind
of you know change is very difficult
because again if we're trying to
innovate improve the platform add new
features and you know fix new bugs we
have to in this architecture go to each
and every application team and
essentially beg them to kind of upgrade
to the latest and greatest which also
makes things extremely challenging in
practice for us and of course you know
enforcement of you know appropriate
usage of this framework is also quite
tricky so I suppose the question here is
is there a middle ground right the you
know between the the centralized
solution that we had and the kind of
more distributed solution using
frameworks where you know we don't have
the centralized kind of problems going
on is there something that would give us
the best of both roles and you know
without kind of the problems that come
with these two kind of architectural
patterns and essentially the answer to
the question presented itself with the
introduction or at least the
introduction for us to the scythe car
pattern so when we learned about this
particular pattern we were extremely
excited because this was we immediately
recognized this that this pattern would
be essentially the next step in in kind
of evolving our overall architecture
especially as a platform team and the
idea is pretty simple we essentially
take again whatever the microservices
framework was doing or you know the
centralized kind of solution and we
extract that into a sidecar proxy
and that psycho proxy would facilitate
the same use cases and requirements but
no longer be actually hard-coded in the
application while still maintaining that
decentralized kind of characteristic and
so this solution is beautiful because
you know it's it's transparent it's
fully polyglot we only have to implement
it once we don't need to port it to all
of the different technology stacks it's
fully decentralized and you know it's
also efficient because we're not adding
those kind of multiple remote hops on
the network so very excited to kind of
start implementing this thing and as we
start kind of thinking about okay how do
we get sidecars on to each and every
workload that we're running the first
thing you realize is well obviously
somehow we'll have to kind of you know
manage and maintain the operational
semantics of each and every sidecar that
we have in our architecture right so we
need to kind of be able to dynamically
configure these things and change how
they behave you know you know as the
conditions of our overall system are
changing and so you know obviously we
need some type of control plane to
manage all of this and so this is kind
of the architecture or the architectural
idea that we landed on and up until thus
far I've only shown you kind of general
patterns and boxes and arrows I suppose
the big question now is okay how do we
go about actually implementing this what
are the ready kind of solutions that we
could employ to get you know some
architecture like this to kind of work
for us and so we're actually in a in a
in a very luxury type of position
because you know in this day and age
there are many different types of
service meshes that one could kind of
choose from to kind of realize this
particular architecture now for us since
we were very early to the game with this
particular kind of solution
you know we essentially adopted the you
know essentially the the first service
mesh that that came out at least that we
knew of
and that was linker D so linker D kind
of brought about this this kind of
revolution in thinking with regards to
kind of handling platform concerns in a
sidecar and and we were very quick to
kind of start to kind of think about how
do we bring it into our architecture
what do we need to do to get to make
this thing a reality
and so you know as being Walmart
obviously we're not a start-up we can't
just like take something that is ready
and just think you know it's just gonna
work for us we need to integrate it into
a larger pre-existing architecture and
so we already had systems that you know
for for service registration and
Identity Management for cloud
configuration and the system for
telemetry and alerting and you name it
which was essentially our kind of defect
Oh control plane and you know the
beautiful thing about link ID is the
fact that it's quite modular and we
could kind of extend it and implement
plug-ins so that's what we did we
implement the whole bunch of plugins
integrated into our existing ecosystem
in the pre-existing architecture and we
essentially hit the ground running now
the other interesting thing is that we
were also implement a policy engine or
actually reported the existing policy
engine that we also had in the previous
solutions and now had had that execute
and link ready directly in the sidecar
so we even had a transparent
backward-compatible solution for this
kind of next-generation architecture
now again us being Walmart and having
this this kind of diverse landscape of
technologies and use cases and
requirements and and you know immense
scale there's always room for you know
different solutions to coexist and so at
this point we're also thinking about or
going forward with adopting sto as a
service mesh and STL is actually quite
beautiful as well very modular and we're
doing the same kind of exercise with
integrating it into a kind of
pre-existing architecture and what you
see here on the picture it doesn't
really depict the integrations that
we've done because I don't really have
enough time to kind of go into detail
about that so feel free to kind of reach
out to me after the talk but essentially
you milk this kind of a pretty much
default set up with sto - a couple of
subtle differences so for one we're not
leveraging the egress gateway at this
point we've kind of offloaded its kind
of concerns on to the side cars directly
and the other thing is that we're we
decided not to use the the policy mixer
which essentially means that we're not
leveraging the native policy enforcement
that sto provides and that's for the
reason because we have our own policy
engine
and we need to be backward-compatible
once again with all of this pre-existing
architecture and so therefore we we
essentially started off actually with
implementing an external mixer adapter
but since our policies are not really
properly cashable doing remote policy
enforcement it's quite expensive and you
know the latest these numbers weren't
really where we wanted them to be
however it's the only an envoy we have
this kind of awesome thing where
essentially there's some type of JIT
compiler inside of Envoy so you can kind
of sent send Lua scripts to envoy and
then thereby have it kind of execute any
additional semantics that you want and
so what we ended up doing is kind of
porting our existing policy engine to
Lua and essentially leveraging that to
get the same kind of transparent
backward-compatible set up but now with
this do so there's that so now if
there's one thing I'd like you to take
away from at least my part of this
particular talk is the fact that as
we've kind of been evolving our
architecture and making steps into kind
of introducing new patterns and
everything essentially the commonality
is that with every improvement we make
we're taking you know an old set of
problems and solving them but thereby
introducing a brand new set of problems
and so we're not under no illusion that
you know the service mesh is some type
of you know silver bullet that solves
all problems for ages to come right
clearly there will be you know a brand
new set of challenges which will take
you know things to the next level now
what are those next set what is that
next set of kind of challenges I have
some ideas I don't know exactly yet
perhaps I'll have an answer next year
but you know we're very excited with
this kind of new evolution especially as
a platform team so with that I will
thank you for your attention and please
give a warm welcome to projector
[Applause]
so thank you Georgie and I think Georgie
said it really well we have to make sure
that we solve the challenges that you
face as you bring in all of these new
technologies so Georgie let me tell you
about a set of challenges I keep hearing
from Google cloud customers and that's
like Georgie mentioned a very nice
pattern on how they went to the service
mesh similarly we have questions from
customers that how do I go and bring
service mesh into my brownfield or how
do I go and containerize into my
existing brownfield deployment because
if you really think of the customer they
don't really care about service mesh
they're not really caring about
containers what they are really asking
for is infrastructure and data
scalability they want smaller
independent development teams they want
to ship faster and they want to keep or
deploy services wherever they want but
they want to manage all of these
uniformly and they definitely don't want
to build the services management
infrastructure or manage it and they
want to migrate from their starting
point at their pace so there are four
transformational technologies that I
keep hearing customers ask on how to
bring into their brownfield micro
services containerization service mesh
and serverless
we have several different patterns I'm
going to talk about one or two patterns
on how customers do this but one
frequent question I hear is should i
mesh first or should I continue eyes
first and I'm going to describe two
different approaches these are inspired
by our two real-world customers on how
they actually did it or how they're
thinking of doing it let's talk about
customer a now their strategy is to mesh
first and then containerize why is that
so one thing I want to actually say
before even we deep dive into customer a
is that there is a very common
misconception that service mesh is for
containerized services and actually
that's not true so let's look at our
customer a this is a pretty big customer
they started their journey to Google
cloud a few years back and they had one
big monolith and then they chopped it up
so it went to 20 micro services then
they got it to Google Cloud
chopped it up further they got 80
microservices they were able to get the
agility that you get with microservices
but there's a problem too because they
went from managing one monolith to going
and managing hundreds of services and so
in their in their set of goals getting a
way to go manage these seamlessly easily
uniformly was much higher than going and
container izing them first and so they
said we'll go and adopt the service mesh
first and then we will continue and
obviously if you think of it if you went
and containerized a monolith you
probably wouldn't get much anyways so
what was their blueprint what did they
do this starting point was a vm based
set of services obviously this is just a
very small subset of what services they
ran then they added the citecar proxy to
their vm based services they also
deployed an ingress now ingress is a
very critical part of service mesh
because that is where you are guarding
the entry point your mesh and you want
it to provide DDoS defense you want it
to be very robust because that is where
a lot of the your external traffic comes
in hits and so they they had an ingress
to provide a secure and programmable
entry point of their mesh and then they
layered in the service mesh control
plane and then they moved some of their
services from VMs to containers and they
lived happily ever after
at this point you should be asking me
but how so let's take a step back and
let's see how they actually did it now
every customer has a strategy generally
when they do this type of transition or
transformation and one of the strategies
that customer a had was to go with
managed services very well possible and
this was simply so that they could move
make them move faster without having the
expertise in-house to go manage the
infrastructure or even build it so they
had four main considerations what do I
go and use for container management
where what do I do with the service mesh
control plane where do I get that as a
managed service where do I get an envoy
image from and then who manages the
envoy lifecycle because that's one of
the frequent questions we get as well so
here is the approach they took
essentially for container orchestration
they use GK which is Google kubernetes
engine
for the service mesh traffic control
plane they're planning to use traffic
director we just went beta yesterday for
the opinionated and certified image they
used an image from Ted trade and then
for the envoy lifecycle management they
plan to use a tread trade solution as
well and we'll talk about it shortly so
I'm not going to deep dive a lot into GK
because there's several excellent talks
on it I highly recommend recommend
watching them but let's go to traffic
director so what exactly is traffic
director if you really think of adopting
the service mesh one is the
transformation inside your organization
as Georgie spoke about and in the second
part of it is also having pieces in the
control plane that are delivered to you
as a service and so that's why yesterday
in u.s. keynote we launched traffic
director it's our new GCP managed
service for the service mesh and there's
also a detailed talk on traffic director
from yesterday so here is what it does
first of all imagine that you have your
data plane that's comprised of your VM
or container based services you go and
inject your envoy proxies in there and
then the traffic director becomes the
control plane for it it will give you
global load balancing it will offload
the health checking from your envoy
instances it will also give you a
traffic driven auto scaling it will also
give you a bunch of traffic control
capabilities and if you already use
envoy you're familiar with those
Canaries traffic splitting traffic
steering mirroring circuit braking and
so on and the nice part is it's GCP
managed so you will get a production
grid SLA a G R so it takes a lot of the
toilet of going and managing this stuff
one of the key things that we emphasize
when we built this out is it has to work
for VMs and containers out of the box so
if you actually look at my example here
the first service is essentially self
managed docker the second one is a VM
based service and then the third one is
a kubernetes engine service so it is
able to manage all of these
heterogeneous environments very
seamlessly and then you can have things
like deploying your instances anywhere
that's what you get out of the global
load balancer and what that really means
so why is global load balancing
important the reason it is important is
that first of all you don't need to
figure anything to make that happen all
you do is create a service put your
instances in whichever part of GCP
regions that make sense for you or where
your users are and then you turn on
traffic director and what it will do is
that if your service in region let's say
all of the instances for a service go
down when the traffic is coming to that
region it will seamlessly redirected or
overflow to another region and you don't
need need any configuration to make that
happen that's implicitly built in into
the traffic director there's another
very interesting reason I brought up
traffic director in this talk which is
how do you go make the transition from a
vm based service to containers there is
a construct called network endpoint
groups which I'll talk about
so imagine initially your service was
sitting in the VM and we have what is
called managed instance group that's
where you specify all your VM endpoints
and then your service is essentially
instantiated into that now imagine you
wanted to containerize that service
there's a construct called Network
endpoint groups and so you go create a
service service one prime and you add
all of the container endpoints inside a
network endpoint group the network in
front groups lets you see those
individual containers and so you can
load balance to them you can do traffic
control to them individually and so now
what you do is you have a service the
same version of the service which is in
in VM instances in another one which is
sitting in containers and so you send
traffic to both you have control knobs
and you can say 99% goes here 1% goes
here and so on and so forth once you do
that then what you do is you start
draining your VM based service so slowly
slowly slowly you start shifting the
traffic to your containers and then
eventually what you can do is you can
drain away your VM based service and you
can do all of this without disruption
which is why it's really huge from the
point of migrating a given service from
VMs to containers and then this will get
even easier because we have a plan to
support both a managed instance group
and a network endpoint row behind the
same service and so you don't even need
to create create another service you
just create a network endpoint group and
then slowly migrate your traffic from
their managed instance group to a
network endpoint group so it just gives
you a very easy way to go from VMs to
containers for a given service
the second part of the problem is like
how do we go and manage the envoy
lifecycle this is a question I get often
asked often and I wanted to invite thee
from dead trade to talk about some of
the solutions they have in this space hi
everyone I'm deep from Detroit I'm a
software engineer to trade I'm very
lucky to be here I mean thank you for
doctor so so the question is how we do
the Alpha lifecycle management so the
challenges in with alpha lifecycle
bantman will be like where do we get the
Android binaries I mean getting the
trusted and updated build of alpha is
not easy I manic building yourselves
probably will be a torture and then
there should be another one like
integrated for nobility check and
scanning and how if there is a fixes on
upstream how you get it and then how do
you exactly do it that upgrading your
Envoy so here that's right we do this
some tooling that do the initialization
and do the continuous check in your
infrastructure and we do this out of the
tak pernah will check and so on and so
forth and we also offer how to upgrade
that so here this is dar gaterboy
guarana is one of our products that we
won't ue lunch it is in still in preview
but we will do this build distribution
of envoy it is trusted it is certified
and there is there will be a mechanism
on how to upgrade envoy and also how we
do the indicated and integrate the
scanning for patching on point okay so
get on void by a trade will said will
open the access of the build pipeline
itself it will be there for public and
we committed to work with the community
bringing tested Android built with low
cost in your site
so we also work hard to integrate that
our patching
to upstream so we also we have
additional protocol support if you need
it and we have full attention support
from antennas inside to trade so we have
one senior maintenance in debt rate and
and for and for proxy and another
maintainer so this is a case when you do
the phone with scanning synthetic attack
again to do to do formulated scanning
one of this is a synthetic attack so
basically do checking on so we have fun
for a built there in our local or in
your environment and then we do the
synthetic attack on that and we check if
it is for inevitable or not so this is
this kind of a mechanism will be
integrated can be standalone or it can
be integrated to to your environment so
more than that we we also offer alpha
equals customization because probably
you need that I mean so this is olive
oil at its core is extensible you can
basically write your very own extension
in fact this eccentricity drives the
adoption of envoy so this is an
invitation free for you to contribute
your envoy you can check out envoy on
how to extend envoy itself so this is
the integration with well when you get
the envoy from someone else third party
like to trade probably you want to ask
is it compatible with any contra plate
out there so we do this integration with
Google traffic director and our cheese
car walking for observability so we have
front-end running in a VM pointing to
user service at first the user service
points to profile service that runs on
VM and after that we gradually program
traffic director to point to the profile
surface to on on kubernetes so as
protectors on to you that we will drain
the traffic from vm to
by programming the traffic director so
this is a video of the demo so first we
have like two different services running
deployed in in in kubernetes
and and VM and then we gradually apply
the rules to the traffic director so we
can move from VM to coburn edits so as
you see that here once we implement the
the policy the routing from VM to
Cabrera's we will see changes in the UI
so let's just wait okay so as you see
that when we move the traffic from VM to
Corona days it will so fix on the UI
it's 50/50 traffic's so I think that's
all for me I'll give it back to
projector thank you Thank You D and I
think if you didn't see the hearts they
were changing between white and red and
so that was the 50/50 that was happening
in there so coming back to so we spoke
about customary and he showed us also
how to go inject your own voice and
there's a bunch of capabilities they
provide but then there's a different
type of customer too so let's talk about
customer B this is a customer based out
of a pack and they had a different set
of goals which was let's containerize
first and then we will mesh so how did
they do it it seems like the common
theme is a monolith on Prem I need to
add some more blueprints where that's
not always the case but even this
customer had a monolith than sat on Prem
and they said we need to move to the
cloud while we move to the cloud we also
want to do some refactoring and then we
want to make sure that as our services
move to cloud they are more and more
modern and so that was their goal now
what is the strategy that they deployed
the first thing that they did actually
is not much in that they left the
monolith on Prem then they took Google's
global load balancer and then they put a
set of API gate four instances behind
that and as you can see each of these
has a different purpose so there's TLS
termination DDoS defense that they got
out of the global load balancer the API
gateway obviously did API level routing
we have several products like Apogee as
well that you can use then you have as
you notice they wanted to do everything
in a way that it their services got
containerized as they move to cloud so
you can see everything in google
kubernetes engine obviously nothing is
moved there yet
and then you have the on the monolith on
Prem and simply the traffic is coming in
through the global load balancer through
your API gateway and getting routed to
on Prem so again no disruption till this
point of time next what they did is they
took a chunk of a service out of the
monolith you can see service a and then
they put it on Prem when they moved it
they containerized it so when it was
instantiated in Google Cloud it was a
containerized service that was managed
with GK or Google kubernetes engine
similarly they got another service B so
you can see that the monolith has
started to shrink and then they got it
into Google Cloud
that's your service B in many of the
service in for many of the services they
were able to rewrite the services to use
G RPC so in the event where you can do
rewrites I would highly recommend
looking at G RPC as your transport
interface and well not you can continue
to use your HTTP and so on so forth as
well now once they did that there were
some systems that or some services that
would never move to GCP an example of
this was a payment service and they
shared this payment service between
various deployments so they didn't want
to move it to Google Cloud but they
still wanted all of the modernization
for that service so what they did is
they chunked out that service put it on
Prem that's what you see with service C
and then what they did is they wanted to
manage it using the same primitives as
they do with GK in Google Cloud so they
brought in GK on Prem and that is what
they used to manage this service now
which is sitting on Prem
but the primitives are same GK in Google
Cloud GK on Prem and then they don't
have to relearn two new primitives in
each case
now obviously one service it's in Google
cloud and other sits on prim they have
to communicate so now you need service
to service communication and that is
what necessitated a look at the service
mesh and then some of these technologies
about service to service communication
so what they did is they first injected
the envoy proxies you can see on service
beyond service see and then they manage
that with Sto
on Prem and then they have an sto
control plane running in GCP as well at
this point of time most people want to
get out of running the control planes
themselves and so now with traffic
director they in GCP side they are going
to manage the traffic control plane
using traffic director and then for the
rest of the pieces they'll continue to
leverage sto and in the future once we
support a hybrid model where traffic
director can manage instances on Prem
then they will do the same thing for the
ISTE oh and in the east you that is on
prin will remain as a fallback so in
case traffic director can't communicate
with instances it will fall back if you
really think of it the next big
innovation or the next big I wouldn't
call it a challenge I think it's an
opportunity for innovation is around
Federation of all of these control
planes and see you will see a lot of
conversations around this but this is
essentially the thing that they deployed
and so if we had to summarize the steps
this is what it looks like so they went
from a monolith and if you just go one
two three four five six those are the
steps that they took to get to a modern
architecture so in all of this I know we
spoke about a bunch of solutions we had
we had Georgie describe how Walmart does
it we had D describe some of the
solutions from Ted trade we also have a
bunch of solutions in Google cloud and
one of the questions I often get asked
by customers is should we use Google
cloud products because they are best or
richer but do they lock us in and it's a
very frequent question that I get and my
question always back to them is what if
you could get both you get best of great
products but there's also no lock-in and
the key to making that happen is
essentially the open interfaces so we'll
talk a little bit more about that but
the first thing so let's take a look at
the migration tools here there is no law
because you're essentially using these
to do possibly a one-time migration I
don't know how many of you attended the
keynote but if you did you saw the
announcement of a product called anthos
migrate and then it's at beta it Auto
migrates VMs from on-prem into GK and so
there is very minimal effort on your end
to do it there's an excellent talk on it
as well and then what that means is when
you use and it's it's very holistic in
its approach so you can see it does
discovery migration planning there's a
whole set of steps that it does to get
your VMs your into GK in Google Cloud
and so what that means as your own folks
can actually take the time and focus on
managing your applications without
really having to worry about how to do
the migration and so on and so forth now
once you've migrated or even when you
are in GCP the question is what are the
tools you should use and where should
you worry about locking so the answer is
wherever you find an open interface that
is where you don't have to worry about
locking because if you don't like
something you can swap it out as long as
the interface is open and I'll give you
an example let's say you ask you as a
starting point your our load balancing
customers you don't really care about
the service mesh you don't really care
about traffic director initially so
you're looking for another flavor of l7i
lb or something like that and then what
you do is imagine that you suddenly now
said I want to go and modernize my load
balancing and so I want to go look at
the service mesh so there is a huge
bunch of customers who start off his
load balancing customers and then go and
want to become service mesh customers
and in there one of the nice things
about traffic director is when it speaks
to the Envoy it uses XDS api's which is
what the open interface used for any
service mesh control plane that talks to
envoys and so if you don't like traffic
director you can swap it out and it
doesn't even have to be Envoy in your
data plane because as long as that proxy
supports XDS you could bring your own
proxy you could go customize envoy as
long as you preserve that open interface
and so that's the track we are taking to
ensure that there's no lock-in while at
the same time we do want to take away
the toil of managing these control
planes so if you actually there's
another very interesting
of customers who are like I want all of
this modernization without having to
worry about traffic director or envoy
and they are like okay we have a service
sitting which just cannot I cannot go
inject an envoy in there so what do I go
to go do there and so that is why we
created another flavor called l7 I'll be
so it looks like any other load balancer
to you and so what you would do is you
would get all of the benefits that you
get from traffic control and other
primitives from is to you an envoy but
you don't necessarily need to even worry
about a control plane or a data plane or
running on voice it just looks like any
other metal proxy to you and you take it
and you put it in front of your services
what it really looks like under the hood
is this so it is traffic director which
is managing a pool of envoys for you but
it's abstracting all of this out and
just making it look like any metal proxy
to you
so it's which technologies you adopt in
which sequence is a function of the
skillset that you have on in in your
folks or what your goals are or what is
the strategy you want to start with what
are the considerations do you have in
terms of cost time and so on
and once you've nailed that down then it
gets easier to start picking one or more
of these technologies there's another
set of customers who actually is not
from the load balancing pool now they
come in from the point of view of saying
I have these multi cloud services or I
have Micro Services and I want to go and
consistently and uniformly manage them
and so they are probably already GK
customers or they may be looking at GK
several of these might have used envoy
in various forms and shapes many of them
may be open sources to your users and so
that is where again you have a whole
slew of options in here ranging from
open source to Google manage and the key
in each of these so like whether do you
self manage kubernetes or whether use
our GK or whether you use GK on Prem
it's the same set of API isn't
primitives which means you don't get
locked in you can switch between each of
these similarly if you use traffic
director or you use is to to talk to
envoy or you have your homegrown control
plane that talks XDS v2
you don't get locked in because you have
the capability to go and switch because
the API is and the interfaces are open
and then there's another one which I
think we don't talk about enough which
is G RPC
if you have services that are using HTTP
HTTP 1.1 etc and you want to bring in
HTTP 2 as an example then you would you
bring in HTTP 2 you would bring in G RPC
and so on if you have services that you
cannot rewrite then you can keep it as a
goal and save it up for your phase 2
then the next thing which I often get
asked so all of these but there is a set
of people who don't want to see any
infrastructure at all whether it's
service management infrastructure with
this container orchestration and so on
and that is where really if you were
there yesterday or day before you heard
about cloud run that's essentially
serverless and again the same question
like do we get locked into your
solutions and the answer is no because
if you look at it first as cloud run so
it's fully managed you deploy your
workloads you don't see the cluster it's
fully managed service for you but then I
have a GK cluster so then you go and use
cloud run on GK and then what that lets
you do is you run the server list side
by side your containers or your existing
workloads
and then it runs seamlessly but then a
lot of you also have on cram or other
deployments of kubernetes and then you
are like what about cloud run there and
so that's what can I do
let's you do I don't know how many of
you attended all of these talks but
they're excellent talks that go through
these three options and the keys again
the same you're using the same tooling
the same API is across the board and
wherever you run kubernetes and then you
get the same primitives without having
to relearn and I think that is the
broader theme I want you to take away
from a lot of these services that are
being built so when we say we build
tools for multi cloud a very key aspect
of it is it has to support these open
interfaces so which brings me back to
the end so we spoke about Walmart's
journey we spoke about customer a who
first meshed and then containerized and
then we spoke about customer B who
actually first containerized and then
meshed and imagine that there are three
or more other patterns where they're not
necessarily starting from monoliths in
fact we have a talk today where we
talked about how service mesh is equally
applicable to telco workloads so one of
the key things about these technologies
is they don't really make assumptions
about whether it's VMs containers
whether it runs in Google
elsewhere like these are very good
abstractions from that point of view and
so how do you use them and when to use
them actually boils down to having a
plan and here are the typical steps that
are common across these five or six
blueprints so when you start your
journey to going and migrating your own
workloads or even bringing all of these
technologies to brownfield you have to
start with your goals like what are your
goals why is it that you want to bring
in and hopefully the answer is not just
because they are cool because all of
these are extremely cool technologies
but there has to be some business
scholar there has to be something around
agility or some problem that it solves
for you and that is the crux of it
honestly once you've identified that
then you can map to one of these
strategies will have a lot more papers
that go out that describe each of these
in detail and more and so once you've
identified your strategy then the
strategy will let you choose tools and
that will depend on what what is the
kind of tool you want like I would say
the table stakes is open interfaces like
look for open interfaces because then
you can change your mind you can swap
things out and bring in new tools and
this could be Google Cloud tools this
could be third-party tools often we have
a lot of complementary tools for the
problems that you face and we don't have
a solution so identify your services and
tools make sure you've done your due
diligence on them once you've done that
most of the success stories that we see
our customers who have had an MVP use
case which means that there's a there's
a set of services they identified and
then they execute the strategy with
those small set of services and then
once they see success they will go and
optimize because obviously they their
learnings from their first phase of
execution and then they'll optimize in
its rinse repeat and in all of these
one of the critical bits is essentially
to automate automate automate I can't
stress that enough but again the success
stories of making these things
repeatable easy to manage is that you
bring in these CI CD pipelines we have
customers who manage code is like code
in CI CD pipelines and it just makes
their lives that much easier so I know
it was a bit of a whirlwind tour but we
hope he gave you at least a flavor of
the various strategies you can use to
bring in service mesh containers and
modern technology
into your brownfield so with that thank
you
[Music]